no bloquee económico aquí en directo
América de Francia 24 en el hablandón
comenzamos hablando de Los grandes
exportadores de petróleo que se reúnen
para definir si suben la producción para
subir los precios así de Raúl pues
sabemos que ya terminó la reunión lo que
no sabemos es Cuáles son esos anuncios
oficiales que van a hacer en Viena sin
embargo la agencia de routers cita tres
Fuentes diferentes para informar que
este grupo liderado por Arabia Arabia
Saudita y sus aliados encabezados por
Rusia acordó recordar en dos recortar en
dos millones de barriles por días oferta
de crudo en la práctica de esto supone
que los precios podrían subir Y es que
hace tres meses un barril costado
alrededor de 120 dólares y países como
Estados Unidos que se oponen
rotundamente al cierre de los grifos
creen que esta es una estrategia
precisamente para recuperar esos niveles
hablemos ahora uno de nuestros temas
favoritos de qué de Twitter por supuesto
porque ahora el unbox
se dijo que sí que sí quería comprar
Twitter y la acción por supuesto se
disparó recordemos que todo lo que dice
él donde invierte pues se valoriza Así
es Raúl finalizaría Entonces esta
batalla legal antes del juicio que
estaba previsto para comenzar el 17 de
octubre ahora el considerado hombre más
rico del mundo debe Buscar los recursos
para la compra en un momento nada bueno
para los bancos que están afectados por
la turbulencia económica y también por
las altas tasas de interés que mantienen
a los inversionistas alejados de las
apuestas riesgosas Danny bueno Entonces
digamos qué va a pasar de ahora en
adelante como ha evolucionado el precio
de esta empresa Bueno observemos
entonces la evolución del precio de la
acción de Twitter en marzo estaba apenas
por encima de los 30 dólares una vez se
anunció el acuerdo avanzó hasta más allá
de los 50 pero con los cines y venir es
y la enorme batalla legal que enfrentó a
las
provocó esto Una gran volatilidad que
llevó a la acción a perder buena parte
de su valor hoy en día están en 52
dólares muy cerca de los 54,2 que
prometió pagar y esto quiere decir que
la capitalización bursátil de la
compañía o sea el valor en bolsa es de
unos 40.000 millones de dólares un
poquito menos de los 44 mil millones que
cuesta todo este acuerdo hablemos de los
indicadores económicos y ya sé
seguramente por dónde vamos a comenzar
vamos a comenzar Desde luego por Twitter
cuyas acciones se dispararon el martes
22% en Wall Street pero hoy abrieron
cayendo más del 2%. la bolsa de Nueva
York Tuvo una apertura negativa también
rompiendo una buena racha de dos
jornadas seguidas ganando entre el 2 y
el 3%. un escenario que no vivía hace
mucho tiempo y en cuanto a los precios
del petróleo a propósito de esa reunión
de la OPEP también avanzan después de
iniciar la jornada en rojo el precio del
brent de referencia para Europa se
acerca a los 93 dólares por barril sube
uno por ciento el W ti también comienza
a subir con fuerza porque hay temor de
que la oferta siga bajando y listo sigue
defendiendo su plan económico lo hizo
ante el congreso de los conservadores en
Reino Unido pues es la primera ministra
británica dio su esperado discurso en
Birmingham y alentó a los diputados
conservadores a unirse en torno a su
proyecto económico más temprano
conversamos con nuestra corresponsal en
Londres Luisa Pulido quien nos contó
detalles
buenas tardes y este coincide además
justo hoy que se cumple el primer mes
del disfraz como primera ministra si una
visión muy clara se diría para la
recuperación de la economía muy enfocada
en cómo recuperarla en medio de esta
crisis económica como promover la
inversión extranjera e insistió en ese
principio ideológico del partido
conservador y es en el recorte de
impuestos Pese a que su paquete
financiero ha causado todo tipo de
crisis en los últimos días lo resumió de
la siguiente manera crecimiento
crecimiento y crecimiento tratando de
dar tranquilidad a los mercados que han
estado en crisis justamente por ese
paquete financiero lista dijo que el
gobierno el ministro de finanzas cuasi
cuarta en va a seguir trabajando muy de
cerca con el banco de Inglaterra y dejó
claro entonces que el ministro no se irá
que ha sido una de las solicitudes que
se ha hecho en los últimos días que el
ministro por esta crisis en que la libra
se yo a sus niveles
récord debía irse pero hoy ratificó que
no la primera ministra también dijo que
el Reino Unido seguirá dando apoyo
económico y de entrenamiento a las
tropas ucranianas por el tiempo que sea
necesario y dijo que está segura que
Ucrania resultará vencedora en esta
guerra frente a Rusia nuestra
corresponsal en Reino Unido Luisa Pulido
Danis por supuesto Gracias por toda la
información económica mañana Claro que
sí